Cuba says it has uncovered a human
trafficking ring that recruits its
citizens to help fight Russia's war in
Ukraine Cuba's foreign Ministry says the
network operates from Russia and targets
Cubans who live there and even some who
live in Cuba the Cuban government says
it's working to dismantle the criminal
organization and has initiated criminal
proceedings against those responsible
but for more on this we're going to go
to Rosa Maria Paya who is the founding
director of Cuba decide campaign she
joins us live from New York thank you
very much for being on this NewsHour
first of all what more details do you
have about this trafficking ring do we
know how many people have been caught up
in it
hello thank you thank you so much for
for having me and I think that the first
thing that we should understand is that
there is no way in which the Cuban
regime is going to acknowledge that they
have been involved in sending
mercenaries to Ukraine because that
would that would mean to cut
relationships with many uh with many
countries and and the other thing is
that sending you a military personnel or
even worse enrolling young Cubans to
fight in Putin's war in Ukraine is the
latest contribution in the alliance
between Havana and Moscow actually from
the beginning The Invasion the given
dictatorship is exploding it's political
and Military alliance with small school
and it's doing it in the Diplomatic
realm as well as the as in the
information Warfare the Cuban regime
voted along Russia to prevent that
emergency meeting to discuss the
invasion in United Nations and since
then has put all their diplomatics
resources to work uh trying to convince
other countries to vote with Russia or
at the very least to abstain in United
Nations and it has been also using their
Communications to support the fake news
coming from the company right I just
want to stick to the the trafficking
ring for the moment if we may could you
just confirm how many people you think
have been caught up in it and what proof
you have
yes uh we do not have numbers of how
many Cubans are now involved in in
Russia or directly in Ukraine we know
that the flights are have been departing
from
we know that a Cuban teenagers have been
deceived into uh going to Russia to work
on construction and other kind of jobs
and have end up in the front lines in
Ukraine we know for sure because there
are many pictures and and testimonies in
the in in the internet are public that
members of the Cuban military are now in
Ukraine fighting on their on the Russian
side and we also know and anyone that
knows a little bit how things Works in
Cuba knows that there is no way in which
this
operation can take place on the island
without the knowledge of the Cuban
region for instance no member of the
Cuban military can leave the island can
travel abroad without a specific permit
of the Cuban regime near in a a with a
military agent in the age of going to
the military service can leave the
island without a specific enemy of the
Cuban regime so of course that we are
not going to have the a contract between
the kremely and the Cleveland regime but
the human region have a lot of
explanation to do yeah how long do we
think that this has been going on for is
it something recent or has it began
since the beginning of the war
and since the beginning of the world
these Alliance have been growing more
and more deep actually the ascanel was
in Moscow in November last year and
literally said that Russia can always
count on Cuba and that visit was
followed for uh for a visit of the
Sergey lavrov to Havana to discuss
um
The Alliance of Latin America with the
Russian foreign policy but since the
last three months we have been
encountering more and more evidence of
Cuban members of the military or just
Cuban teenagers in Russia or in Ukraine
fighting in the in the Russian side okay
we'll have to leave it there but thank
you so much for your Insight and your
time that is Professor Maria payer
founding director of Cuba decide
campaign
thank you so much